yeah welcome to this video this is a new
episode of viewer game see I your games
reviewed on the channel yep let's get
going this is a game that was sent to me
by the black player here his handle is
anti shatter and this is an online game
man this is went to handle it's a game
played on chess calm and his opponent
desperado 14 yeah they both are rated
somewhat near nearby each other this
broader 14 is rated 1400 on chest calm
and anti shatter is rated 1300 so that
you can put it into perspective it is a
game that was played with 30 minutes per
side with no increment yeah I CC by
default it shows 15 don't be irritated
by that the times here are not relevant
yeah the real time allotted for the game
was 30 minutes per player so I've got 14
and our viewer here and I switched it to
see it from our viewers perspective I
think that makes sense because he sent
the game to me and he should you them a
game from from his perspective so let's
see we got a [ __ ] on defense and why it
goes for the so-called pan off attack
the capture on d5 and then the move c4
yeah this is a very direct approach
against the kurakin and in line that can
be recommended to players who enjoy a
free piece play yeah white as we see has
very good natural ways to develop his
pieces and quite often we will get a
position that would have an isolated
Queens pawn for example if let's say
Knight f6 is plate which is actually
happening in the game Knight f6 and
let's say just 93 e six right here
develops and
something like that white will have an
isolated creep on in compensation as
compensation for that weakness and
structure he has very nice active pieces
that can come out um down on an
aggressive squares in that game white
plate Knight f3 however this move this
of course are not bad it cannot be bad
it's a good developing move it is
however putting a little bit less
pressure on black then the move Knight
to c3 why is that 93 it's a little bit
more pressing in this situation to
increase the pressure on that d5 pawn
one reason why this can be important is
that black very much would like to
fianchetto his king's bishop yeah to get
castling quickly and have the bishop
pointed tips that was a wrong arrow have
that bishop pointed directly at the iqp
there since rubenstein we know that we
should be in cheto again sighs they
decreed point if possible um here in
fact after g6 on the situation is not so
comfortable for black as a move like
queen bee three can be quite annoying
yeah if Y takes a black takes and why it
takes here then this pressure forces the
movie six and now we see why Knight c3
is more precise we have this combined
pressure on their porn and black now has
to play as we have seen either esox here
which is a bit awkward yeah you don't
want esox ng6 now or what he normally
does is to play Bishop g7 and simply
give up their part and try to play
gambit out of that that's in quite
interesting line actually for black
which is it's a little bit dodgy a
little bit but but interesting to play
this is however far more testing then
Knight f3 that move on is less puts less
pressure on d5 and this makes it a bit
awkward
a bit easier for black now to get their
g6 set up in our view up late nights c6
I would actually consider g60 already
trying to quickly get to get the settle
something like this for example if white
now go screen b3 we can't capture and
cancel yeah and now this is in fact
looking rather stupid in some way
because knight c6 will come with a later
night a5 threat so g6 now would be very
desirable to play but he didn't he
played knight c6 which is of course not
bad just that I would have gone first or
first chance given I would have gone for
the fianchetto white now play Bishop b2
and this is a little bit similar in
nature to neither 3 this move is a bit
passive now I think it's more testing to
put the night out first and again put
some pressure on that pawn here black
has some choice you can play e6 now
that's a very conservative approach but
your default is more interesting yeah
setting up that pin that can lead to
very sharp play after C takes Knight
takes Queen B 3 1 and this is currently
the fashionable move g6 this is actually
what I play in this position it's not
that I play the calc on that often but
sometimes you can get this position of
our openings from the English opening
why a c4 c5 I don't want to spend too
much time on the opening of it here
after g6 some there are a couple of
interesting possibilities this is one of
them the white SS funny intermediate
move threatening on f7 and now black
usually goes here why text em black has
to give up that piece he cannot rescue
it if you look at this for example check
yeah and this is a disaster for black
yeah nice jejeje six ticks ticks
and here black goes back and now plays
e6 and this casual position is very very
interesting i recently had that in a
blitz game i think it was is not
released yet that's that game but will
be will be shortly that's a very
interesting position for both sides to
play like a scott the bishop pair but of
course it's got a somewhat bad structure
there in general is something that I let
that quite like form for black to play
yeah why do I ever played Bishop e2 and
now of your plate e six which is not bad
but i would go g6 if possible she and
shetow against the coming i QP structure
a good thing is also if you look at this
and what goes for c5 which you did in
the game in this kind of setup even here
the bishop is nicely placed because it
pressurizes the d4 pawn and supports the
further if i push so it's really better
on g7 okay e six cancels bishop g6 yeah
here and rather play Bishop e7 ER
because we see in the game ly 25 here
and Bishop g5 and now we see a typical
thing if you put the bishop somewhere
else than e7 in this case it's e7 then
you're sitting in their pin and it's a
little bit awkward to play now here you
go on age six yeah that you can do and
visual h4 that was played yeah and now
you're sitting there and you wonder how
am I ever going to get rid of that
bloody pin yeah of course you can play
g5 but this is not very desirable and
yeah how are you going to play and never
move the Queen from d8 that looks
difficult to do it's a it's a little bit
awkward here um still I think that black
should probably castle and still has of
course a playable position he doesn't he
didn't commit any any serious mistake or
anything
what I pointed out to now and mostly am
yeah suggestions how to play more
ambitiously and a little bit more
precisely but they weren't any mistakes
committed yet however Lex next move our
viewers next move is a mistake he played
b6 this move from a strategic point of
view it's very much commonplace in this
structure when those pawns have advanced
that is c4 c5 and d4 you often want to
attack this chain and would be six is
doing that this is actually coming at a
moment where yeah well before it's even
possible because happy I can I can put
it on the board yeah before Knight takes
Queen a force rather embarrassing but
the problem is really it would be great
if what would be committed to capturing
yeah then we would recapture um I wonder
prom me with the bishop well we will
recapture and this is definitely to two
blacks gain training the beep horn
against the Seaport and here you
sometimes even have possibilities to do
something with the bishop here maybe a
five Bishop a six if circumstances
permit that the real problem or ever
with the must be six is different and
it's something that happens quite often
if you go um b6 you see what is the
disadvantage of their move it has left a
piece unprotected the knight on c6 the
knight on c6 is not stable anymore it
had a stable home there with the pawn on
b7 now this is gone and white in fact
has some opportunity to use this fact to
his advantage what white can do here is
she can play Queen a4 or Bishop b5
they're both strong using that pin yeah
and now it's really awkward how should
black respond probably black has to go
Bishop d7 if you go Bishop d7
after this and Bishop b5 it gets also
really really awkward yeah now we have
to play probably knight to e7 and I mean
white can just continue here with 93 or
you can consider this move which sends
this Bishop home this is not totally
clear cut as black hair Scotty 50 but in
general it looks a bit awkward it really
does and you can argue if Bishop b5
immediately might be stronger yeah
actually that might be the case here if
here night is seven c6 back this is
clearly a better comparison because here
there is no e5 coming let's say white is
playing a normal move Knight c3 do we
want to go back let's say 6i don't even
threatening something but we can go back
and this is awkward from like he's kind
of boxed in that porn is a nuisance you
cannot go b5 you can take you it's it's
it's really really a problem I think
this is probably the more promising
reply even though on even hear it it
gets tricky after Bishop here that's
Queen D 7 which is kind of okay as we
get in a six but the problem is 95 this
is some an issue now we are again again
threatening here on c6 and yeah what to
do I think black has to go g5 as weird
as it looks this is not so clear so
probably Bishop g3 yeah and now black is
in trouble yeah that night only five is
attacking on c6 and probably black
doesn't have anything better than take
that and this is just very very awkward
you've got many weak squares and the
where when you go with you King Black is
just the trouble yeah that was something
that white could have done after b6 and
it's something to take from this game if
your opponent planes a move that that
basically under fence one of his pieces
yeah giving him some liability it's
often a good idea to check the moose
that a technet piece directly sometimes
you can push it back on gain the
initiative simply because while you
attack it he has to react yeah and often
this is kind of piling up if something
is uncoordinated it always has to be
checked if we can attack that piece that
is weak spot directly and this is what
white should have done here he played a
93 however just developing and now our
viewer captured on c5 yeah that's
certainly um yeah very principled after
having played p6 however white again had
a good possibility here in Bishop b5
even now this is a rather strong move
setting up the pin you know this is
certainly promising for wide eee 5 is
not easily played or alternatively if
the Queen takes there is screen 84 which
again is very awkward just to go back
and now let's say Ruby one threatening
95 but there are many many good ways now
we see that white is fully developed in
threatening 95 and black really has huge
problems in coming up with a decent move
probably the best continuation is this
and now castles but here this is just a
better for white without black having
any kind of counter play here you
captured however probably pretty
routinely yeah there's this happens
quite often you get the pawn taken and
you just recapture without thinking too
much here there was an opportunity still
still still on if you have
purif labor should be five yeah now
castles by black and white went 94
that's actually a good move and move
that asked some very important crucial
question what about that see 69 do you
want to defend it or do you want to take
on gear for the black player arguer took
on default which i think is not yeah not
so great I mean you had a very concrete
idea that we would see in there in the
game but i think it was better here to
keep the tension a little bit and play
em probably just Bishop d7 yeah what
about this position if we have checked
this it's very unbalanced black has a
complete center and deep on while white
has three pawns against one point on the
clean side quite often this will lead to
very sharply as the queenside pants will
try to push forward to get passes while
black will push the center and already
also has a passport the deponent but you
will push the center often trying to
combine that with activating against
White's King very sharp stuff what's
better I'm difficult the same I probably
rather be white but it is some about
equal I guess not a computer believes
that it's about equal it's just I would
probably prefer white a little bit one
reason is that it's not so easy at the
moment for black to actually get that
Center in motion one reason is that this
pin is really awkward and very difficult
to get rid of that means that quite
often you cannot easily go if I for
example as after capture on d5 d5 before
so it's not a center that can be pushed
forward very very quickly
an important point is that here after
Bishop e7 white also has to move f4
which puts a stop to e5 ideas pretty
yeah pretty seriously and it's very very
difficult to get any 5 yeah I think that
this is what you should have done and
not taking taking is a typical case of
releasing the tension and quite often
releasing the tension some kind of
conflict if one side resolves it it's
often to that size disadvantage it's
often better to keep the tension yeah
and here that was probably one of those
cases where Bishop d7 was a little bit
better if we see and think of this in a
very abstract way yeah we have two
pieces that are in play black exchanges
one piece that is in play but why it
gets his Queen out so in the process
White has actually gained some activity
for that Queen for free it's like a
mathematical equation yeah night minus 9
equals active White Queen yeah and
that's not a good good trade-off you
know what in the process got something
out of that trait it's not a trade on
totally equal terms and the Queen onda
form is not badly placed it's a it's
nice in the center looking at both wings
and it might support that before and so
on push um the thing is I believe that
our view here had a very concrete idea
he went a 580 plate in five and this was
probably was him what he was planning
with that night takes deform forever the
c5 move has a drawback I think what you
probably should do is something like a
60 Bishop e7 again if we go a 6 for
example you have to cover that let's
square um then then F 4 p-8 be four is a
typical continuation I just want to show
that type of
that might might happen yes White has
huge space c 5 and so on g5 is
relatively well under the reps and I
think why does somewhat better the
computer gives white Harbor porn which
seems fair so it's a little bit more
than a little bit more than a miniscule
advantage it's something it's
sustainable but it's not it's not
overwhelmingly grade um he went he 550
and after that it gets very very
critical the thing is it would be nice
if black would be able to push forward
to Center let's say white would move the
Queen again then everything's fine yeah
black can't even consider to start with
g5 and go from here yeah like let's say
in six to prevent any night be five
business and then push forward I know g5
is weakening but well those parts here
in the center they are quite quite quite
strong and if you have such a strong
central presence then weakening with g5
it's not as important this is however
purely yeah pathetically because white
will of course take on f6 and this is
what you did in the game Bishop f6 yeah
now you either give up d 5 or you get to
the game position yeah I mean black can
theoretically speaking do this and try
to get some compensation for his pawn
there it's not going to be enough but
it's um it's not totally terrible let's
say to try to hold this position it's a
it's not very attractive but it's it's a
question if the game is worse actually
yeah because and those in this kind of
situation you always have the hope that
at some point you might get opposite
colored bishops that's a typical thing
why quite often the bishop pair is a
good compensation for porn as you
sometimes can you
your active bishops in that regard that
you swap the the one Bishop that you
need to get opposite colored bishops for
example in a situation like this when y
puts the nights at one point on one of
those central squares can be easily
imaginable that the bishop will take
that night and then we would have
opposite kind of bishops so playing this
with black hair and I said is not a much
fun prospect but it's it's actually a
question if the game is worse leg took
on d4 I understand that you did that i
am not criticizing it's just interesting
that giving up the form might have been
an opportunity yeah rook to e8 you can
also take with the bishop m95 look b 8 b
3 we should be seven again a position
upon down where black hands slide hope
of drawing because we will probably be
able to take that night for opposite
candid bishops not fun but again you
have to be a quite quite modest there
already he took with the rook however
which is of course also more logical
keeping keeping that point for the
moment wyd went 95 and black played
Bishop f5 that's pretty much forced and
rather obvious we have to take they have
to use that bishop to cover their pawn
on d4 yeah now we come to a crucial
moment of this game let's take stock
here what what has happened in the last
couple of moves we have had a
transformation of the pawn structure
black had to take their on d4 which has
destroyed his structure he's got a
double it pawn them however it's a
passer the deep one is passed on d4 so
there is some danger that those pawns
there are two of them agree actually
that these pawns can might do something
Black has got the bishop pair that's
good always useful as
to have white has got a 33 it's done
paint a little bit three against one
majority and if it's um if white
succeeds in making sure that the deep
horns blacks d pawns don't get too
active what can ensure that then those
three pawns against one phone would be a
huge huge asset that probably will win
the game the whole thing I ever now is
very very concrete you cannot get by
with some general considerations here
this position has to be played with very
very concrete and solid calculation what
should why do it's clear that that night
on behive has only one purpose it would
wants to capture that por nada for now
and it's so not a difficult task to go
down and a move that was not played but
I want to show to you now it's a rook a
2d one that would be if you look at this
position from the white side for for one
moment if you collect or if you compile
and all of you of candidate moves you
would probably start with the both rook
moves to d1 because you want to take
that pawn there why not win that point
you want to probably go rook 81 to get
out of this diagonal even though look
everyone should be looked at as well
this is however in comparison not as
clear as after this now that night
doesn't have a great square that's a
difference to rook 81 if we have look 81
and here and the rook can safely take
that so here and here yeah that's um
that's the difference there of those
those two lines
the Rope 81 is probably best answered if
we continue that line with rook e8 now
if you go d3 and jettison the pawn in
that way as we said this and now we
should be too OOP t to note that this
bishop doesn't have many squares to have
six let's say and now why this cashing
in on that part and is close to taking
this for example after Bishop his
success takes takes rook see to White
has an excellent endgame that he will
probably win I mean it's not the easiest
tasks ever task ever but he will
probably win that we see that ultimately
one of those pawns dropped first this
one and then ultimately the second tip
on so something to take on deform it's
just the most logical because it really
gives this night provides us night with
some sense it's on b5 to take their the
white player ever didn't do that it
didn't play book 81 he played a very
mysterious move you played to move a 4
and I honestly I have no idea why I'm
why this was played because it
absolutely doesn't make any sense to me
I mean there are cases where you see a
move and you don't understand the
purpose all right let's say you
understand it's not good but you
understand what the idea was and here
I'm absolutely not sure what the idea
was because the night I mean he secures
the square a three for the light a
little bit more but really you want to
go to a three hmm yeah he wants to go to
a three after a six now wyd went to a
three and this is just an just a weird
idea i miss place that night on the edge
of the board and in the same in the same
process also weakened the Queen side we
have to understand that something like
that we're going to be file is very
awkward always a tech
me too and the points before upon
inspection it cannot push forward the
worst however is that that night on a
three is totally totally offside so in a
very mysterious decision by the white
player in this particular case in this
particular position now it's very
interesting what black plate he played
the move rookie eight and while I
understand the point rupee eight it goes
on hub open file and it also threaten
something this should take sage to
winning upon it's not the best move why
because blackhead something better and
something that really perfectly
addresses why that night be five and
then a four-night a two night in a three
why that night a three idea was a
mistake black now had the very strong
move Bishop to have fire and this is a
move that again serves more than one
purpose those moves are always not
always justice very concrete sometimes
not but moves with more than one purpose
are very often good moose and this move
is a multi-purpose move we intend to
push the three activating that point
further advancing it further opening up
the bishop yeah let's just see this we
are can't be too indirectly I with with
that d3 threat and with the night on a
three hit the look on a one that's very
unlucky situation to be in yeah and
additionally with the bishop on f5 why
it has no chance now no opportunity to
block that pond with putting the bishop
let's undo arrow here I cannot put the
bishop on d3 as a locator that's
controlled and this is an additional
nice benefit that night only three now
cannot even come to see two so white has
totally misplaced his his own position
there with a form and 93 um probably
white will play a move from like that
yeah putting something here to maybe get
in bishop
three but it doesn't really help a lot
let's say black plays some Janice got a
nicer number of options look to be a
this interesting on also look to c 8
this and this is interesting or this
also makes some sets if white now tries
to cover with before we played III and
will win huge amount of material Bishop
f5 was not played but it would have been
exceptionally strong I think very
difficult for white to get some playable
game after that it simply basically hit
the self-destruct button with a four and
93 however this was played a rookie
eight Bishop b3 that's a good and
logical we are blocking that corn
preventing Bishop f5 that is very good
and now our viewer went g6 that has an
idea and not a great one and what do you
see g6 I'm better is probably to start
with a move like this we should be seven
to check on a forum for example like
this we attack here f4 and now a five
this this would be something that is
still rather okay for black yeah no no
real issues however you went g6 and this
is some yeah and that is the radical
idea and that was the idea yeah just
setting up this this trade I understand
the idea from from a activity point of
view this is interesting trying to lift
that blockade to push the pawns further
on but the problem is it's simply you
taking too many you're suffering from
too many strategic problems here the
pawn structure is a total disgrace I
mean it just it just doubled pawns
isolated pawns
what not and why does having this free
against one two three against one on the
queenside which will be very dangerous
so it is really not the way to do it
with Bishop f5 g6 and Bishop f5 and yeah
right now place the news f4 yeah is that
a good move no it's not and it's a
pretty typical mistake that in one shape
or form quite often happens um why Tia
had to ask himself where do I want to go
what is my desired set up in this
position and he has one yeah if we
imagine this night here is really a bad
piece you want to activate it you want
to give it some useful things to do what
black should do is you should start with
the move like move d1 to stop the deep
on so after d3 oops we can happily take
and then next would be this bish this
night moving it away from the edge of
the word possible good squares to go to
our first and foremost d3 yeah there
will be a great locating square
supporting those pawns on 74 and
blocking the deep one wide also might
have the option to travel to f3 and then
take care yeah so so many opportunities
in any case white has a pretty pretty
big advantage here and one problem is
black has no real counter plane what is
blacks not apply you cannot attack one
of white spots they are very securely
and yeah defended in organized white
however okay I have to put let's back
white or ever didn't play what you want
he played the move f4 why is this a
typical mistake because why just had
this this typical impulse okay f4i
attack the bishop he has to move it true
but do we gain from that really
answers no the move f form is just yeah
it's just a tickle yeah it just says
okay move the bishop okay and black is
not blundering it but moving it which is
not tough to do we just retreat that
piece everybody sees that and now what
has wide accomplished with the f porno
on f4 there's a totally different
situation regarding those squares on the
e-file now White has a couple of
weaknesses especially efore and e 3 E 2
is not much of a difference but II form
and III that's a difference and what is
the consequence black has now some
counter play ideas that i would like to
paint but software doesn't get me what
the heck hmm i want to UM paint please
okay i deposit via vermont and fix
something but now we're back and kicking
um yes so this was the position f4 and
as we said these squares have been
weakened and this helps black a lot yeah
he can get this look in here or here
sometimes e2 and generate some counter
play f4 was just moving like half i can
attack your bishop and further
inspection reveals doesn't lead anywhere
okay what would what did why do after
this Bishop f6 let me have a look rook
anyone yeah sure that makes sense and
now black plate rookie three yeah that
looks like a decent enough move it's
activated however here um black had a
slightly better opportunity and this was
a five it's just something that is some
it's a concrete thing that this year
possible in this position after f150 one
has been played a five breaks up the
black and the white power structure the
important point is that after b5 there's
Bishop e7 and now this is hanging and
white cannot even take yes
you would lose its one drawback of f4 so
what is it that white has to do after a
five yes to play 95 after which unlikely
continuation is something like that
black has to step out of that 97 move so
let's say whoopty 8 takes rook c8 and
now we can try to pick up those pawns
the thing is that the most likely
outcome here is an end game like let's
see Roxy one route c 6 t 1 594 check to
make sure takes takes takes takes and
while white has a symbolic advantage
with the upon this will end in a draw if
black is not doing something immensely
stupid a5 was a good opportunity here
because it makes sure that White's pawn
structure is destroyed yeah white
absolutely would like to play b5 to keep
this pawn formation intact but you
cannot as we have seen because of Bishop
we said this is why a five was a good
opportunity here and something that has
to be checked all of the time if the
opponent has a dangerous for information
that might roll forward we have to check
opportunities to kill the soundness of
that structure trying to attack it
isolate pawns here with white taking at
a later stage all those pawns will be
weak there of course the line that we
had is better at first this oops and
then this but we see all of them are
weak and in effect black will probably
win all of those pawns at one point or
get them at least four traits against
the depons possibly the f pawn and then
you will draw maybe a pawn down and game
three against one one on one wing so
blacks aim is to trade off basically the
whole
the whole Queen said you have that
succeeds another big server delay that
succeeds then is very satisfied you have
to be content with such a yeah with that
attitude to just get a draw out of this
moist not possible he played rookie 3
looking for what's interesting as well
but ok rookie three was played night
situ and repeat three rookie for was
made me a little bit tougher yeah now
here White had a good opportunity that
he did not take um instead of playing
night XD for which is what what he did
he had ruegg f3 that was an interesting
alternative trying to get rid of that
active rook if black takes then why'd
some advantage will be very very
pronounced because now all of those
crucial squares are nicely protected and
white even has good chances to get in
the perfect blockade on d3 after Luke f3
black probably should play would be to
and now white can take and we see that
compared to the game yeah let's compare
that to the game White has gained to
move look at three for free he took and
like to go on before so we have gained a
move essentially look every rupee to was
inserted and that is a that was a good
nice way to increase the advantage
basically winning a temple because black
could not take now after night takes
deform black to one before a night f5
yeah interesting here now of your plate
King 2h7 and move that I regarded with
much skepticism it looks a bit passive
but I'm not totally sure and actually if
this is good or not um I was thinking
that black has better chances with rook
28 it might be true but I'm not totally
sure the endgame is very very sharp and
rope
I mean JY to take that pawn and king of
eight we have a funny position at the
moment why these two pawns up but the
deep one is dangerous and of course the
bishop on is potentially the far better
pc than the night the situation is not
clear it's not like just plus 2 or
something white is two points that's not
true white definitely has to be
precisely to keep legs initiative at
babe um a possible continuation it's
difficult to get to get to a conclusive
point yet like let's say here rook takes
a 4 p-1 Roxy eight and nine f5 yeah
deform something something rd four is
not possible right doc there's at c7 but
95 let's let's stop at the point um
maybe black and check on before
something is gay history gained one
pound still under pressure it's still
pour down but I think practical chances
are our okay here for black he can still
hope to to draw this game teen aged
seven looked a bit a bit passive to me
and after all you're giving up on there
as well Group D 5 rupee eight intending
to play rugby one so Luke t8 was very
much preferred of working age seven rook
be eight yeah probably intending would
be one now d2 d1 was played that's a bit
conservative but not bad there was a
better movie even for white in awkward
server delay in Luke g6 looking at that
pawn um bishop has to go there and now
it takes and takes and rook c1 is very
strong for white probably enough to win
because the support is just too
dangerous yeah if black starts to
collect pawns here then this Andrew
d 8 will ensure promotion Luke t6 was a
pretty clear winner however I think
starting from here um the game was
certainly influenced by the time
situation rogue DD one doesn't spoil
anything but it's not as force for quite
obviously yeah black plate King to g6
could have taken on a four as well g4
age five and age three instead of h3
right again had a win but this time it
was trickier with this year that's quite
need to route 26 what is the idea if
black takes we go here jack and now a 96
here's a fork yeah I misread my notes
there when it is night c6f don't need a
note for that it's just a fog Luke g6
was strong but white went age 3 which is
understandable as a typical reaction in
a in a blitz situation or in a very
short time controlled situation just
cover that rook took on a form
call this already lays off for what is
happening here rook took on you for then
c6 was played and black went back to see
for Roxy one I think that that's all
rather logical check like insert that
check here and white chocolate c7 rook
c8 check check all that is totally okay
f6 our king g 7 was a bit bit tougher
and g5 yeah it looks awkward but it's
still not totally easy a five check
check Roxy six if I a black has to push
that pawn that's the only hope hope left
for him yeah here wide already could
have played f5 they are just pushing
things home but he didn't do that you
played rugby one it's a slightly
mysterious understand that rupee aid was
the intention but it has a it has a
drawback OOP and this he probably
overlooked that the hook f2f eight was
possible so it was much better here to
use the f porn right here and push
forward for example like this check
check check check and white wins rather
easily this is a mistake I think he
overlooked that the rook could come back
but the game was certainly already very
heavily influenced by by the time
situation that is some according to the
notes that the black player anti shadow
here sent to me look F to have eight why
it took and what about this end game is
this still a win for white I don't think
so i think that is a draw and in the
game we see how that progressed rue k 6y
a white should have tried actually it's
draw after that sorry wyd still at Kiev
too and with that he would have had at
least a slightly better chances to do
something let's say a three oopsie to a
267 route 86 rooks III and something
like that h1 but it's still it should be
a draw but it's it's a little bit it's a
little bit tougher maybe what can do
something else here maybe white if white
prevents it's still a draw I was just
thinking this is what the engine is
suggesting but it's still a draw yeah
the idea is that engine wants to wants
to get this end but it won't help there
is no way forward at the moment why does
try to run around here with the rook we
will always have checks and you will
counter-attack the H pawn that's it's
still not leading anywhere like this I'm
just staying and if i if i go for the
back check i can give a the ton of
checks check don't don't get anywhere
now it is just as wrong as so it
probably didn't matter what why did I
was thinking that maybe King f2 is a
little bit tougher but it's not a big
difference this is what we got a king of
sadness not really unnecessary could
have taken immediately but she doesn't
it doesn't really matter that much we
get exactly the kind of position that I
had shown earlier check check yeah this
is actually yeah those checks this is a
mistake a little bit I mean it doesn't
really hurt black but it's a typical
thing especially if you have no time you
tend to give checks because it's it
feels right yeah because it feels like
if you give a check you cannot really
make a mistake yes react but in fact
here why does driving the King Black is
driving the king
adverts towards your position it is much
easier here to just cut off on the
second rank and ask but okay what are
you going to do yeah if he does that
okay and what what is he doing shuffling
like that maybe check can even come up
here yeah it's it's totally totally
drawing if you put the rukon the second
rank it's much easier check then the
checks it doesn't really it doesn't lose
Sam I mean it is still a draw even with
the king coming up the board check but
the real issue comes later thing is it
was absolutely not necessary to even let
the King White's King advance that
channel yeah this is this is what
happened there to move 53 and here black
with absolutely no time made a mistake
and this is something that is of huge
practical value here um to to look at
this this situation if you have no time
really no time and you are in a rook
endgame upon down you absolutely never
trade rocks never never never ever
unless you clearly see that you can
liquidate all of the parts even drew gap
seven year and then this just loses the
game I mean the thing is it ends in a
draw off but we will see what happened
because of the time but you can
absolutely never trade rooks when you
are porn down in the rook endgame unless
you're absolutely one hundred percent
thousand percent sure that you get all
the points and here's critically at
black won't get the pawns because it's
protected on g5 and especially in a
situation where the other side has a
protected passer the rook trade will
definitely definitely lose I understand
that this was basically an in Blitzen
bullet mode so we don't sure
be too critical yeah but it's a good
rule of thumb that will be right almost
all the time don't trade routes when you
are porn down in the rook endgame the
king at porn and game will be lost in in
the vast majority of cases unless you
are absolutely sure that it is right and
you can only be totally sure if you have
more time to check it out yeah because
there will only be a couple of
exceptions where the rook endgame or the
component came upon Don will be actually
a draw our viewer landrieu kept seven
and white do saturated yeah now actually
basically almost win it is impossible
now as why it is so active to avoid them
invasion nking f4 doesn't make much
sense it's a time issue king e6 was
better but even King Air Force winning
it's it's black it's absolutely in no
position to avoid what happens check and
here after King f6 King g8 it ended in a
draw why time time whites whites timer
and out so I've been unlucky for the
white player that he didn't get the
victory there which was ultimately
probably deserved one after that rook f7
blunder it ended in a draw so a lucky
end of for our our viewer here who got
saved by the bell so to say that was an
interesting game and I think it was
played on it on a very very decent level
if you consider both players ratings and
the time control yeah they didn't really
commit any any blunder of pieces of
something like that it was a was a very
interesting game if we without going
into much detail um do a quick recap
what did happen here white early on
established that c5 formation gaining
some space and ultimately preparing a
queen cytosol
like was suffering from that pin a
little bit and now with v6 initiated
that play against the chain that is a
good idea strategically but was mistyped
Queen a4 or Bishop b5 between 85 no
Queen a 40 Bishop b5 would have
exploited that but why it didn't take
that chance played 93 and now after
night before that trade as we said was a
bit premature like Wendy five after
which we got that transformation to the
endgame here mysteriously white avoided
rook t1 and played a 4 after rook to e1
it would have had a nice advantage when
after a four night a three-year
blackhead Bishop f5 for very good
position a very good position um instead
he went wookie aid yeah maybe being
tempted by that threat after which white
gotta blow Caden he resolved that with
this Bishop f5 idea and now was in
trouble if white would have played rugby
one you had f forever and now after this
with a five-year a five that could have
gotten enough counter play which she did
not do and he'll end it ultimately into
that very bad end game that continued
for a while without jack I with white
being okay and shag was all very fine
from the white player's perspective
until he ran roop you want and blundered
that f4 point basically yeah and that
rook endgame is a draw even though black
as a pawn down that yeah ultimately
offered that ill-advised drug trade is
probably really due to the to the time
situation so at the end he had a lucky
draw because of the time again I'm
always advocating to play with an
increment converge em 30 minutes and 0
increment is just less I think less
quality of a game as 25 minutes and 10
seconds because you don't get that all
of a sudden draw and Sammy why set a
draw I mean white has two points and
wins easily anyway I think it was a good
interesting game I hope you enjoyed that
I still have tons of your games to go
through it just takes a long while to
prepared and record it and you see I
didn't even expect that this video would
be so long with I hope you enjoy it I
think it was a weather what a good fight
thanks for watching